I was walking hey guys how's it go and I
haven't blogged since CES I don't think
I'm not even sure did I know I did my
shirt here's the daug here's the coffee
we're getting once we just took Matty to
the bed see how to get his I don't know
what the nice thing is to say was anal
gland is anal glands squeezed what do
they call it
I mean a breast express expression we
did that we're gonna take him to get a
bath because he smells like pee because
he pees on himself and then we're gonna
be watching the Steeler game later and
we're also gonna be putting together
Maddie's car he thought of you guys know
what the new trend is apparently pink I
hate so Maddie also got one Maddie
say hello he's so freaking cute I'm so
proud of him for winning World Awards my
best new puppy so thank you guys again
for voting for ahead because honestly
it's it's my biggest accomplishment in
life
oh yeah I have four things that I wanted
to bake for three are you gonna make any
food for games maybe I good yeah okay
see a second he sees another dog he sees
another dog the nice near the merciless
restaurant it just brought Maddie out a
little cup of water about to get his
body cleaned
he got a wild day at the beach he's dead
look at this great breakfast
how's your breakfast it likes you quite
the same thing one bite the potato's
good dog so likes me too the other day
about making sure that I remember to
pick up some chairs well guess what I
didn't remember I didn't remember to
pick up the chairs we are now here
picking up the chairs but I need to make
room for the chairs oh the chairs we
don't it's yours all right I'm gonna go
pick up the top of your back because we
got the chairs now oh yeah I'm ordering
groceries from the phone this is wild
just use account so I'm just gonna get
whatever I want I'm gonna get the finest
organic strawberries right now I'm
trying to find the Nature Valley soft
oatmeal bars ah doesn't she know you're
necessarily children in the car
unattended with the Sun beating down she
doesn't have a dog no dog where's the
dog hello he's 20 minutes with him no
he's have the pond play date but guess
what they have these cute little things
this guy he makes them she said the bags
yeah he has like a sewing machine next
to his bed and he makes them they're
called
any Co creations comm companion sings
echo Nico who cares look how super
awesome is it like an older man I'm not
sure you are let's move made in the USA
good oatmeal bars yeah creamer coffee
cake um could you get some white
chocolate like baker's white chocolate
because I'd like to make some lego man
chocolates oh I'm kidding I'm boiling
sugar so could you go to a good coffee
we need how am I may add more stuff on
here hey what do you want k-keep white
into muscle did you want um the white
chocolate chips
we'll go back and see what go back to
the white chocolate just click white
chocolate and see what it says
mmm
Starbucks haven't seen you and what
actually I don't administer our box in a
while I can't wait to see how cute
Maddie looks and I walked in there I saw
his little face he was like she said he
had a fun play day with all the little
puppies in there
[Music]
Jenna hello hello it's me waiting for my
car I don't know the dogs ready we ready
he's gonna be so cute and fluffy thank
you again
come on let's go let's go
time to watch Steelers Matty time to
watch football we just put together that
light I don't like it there it's gonna
have to go upstairs
Matty do you know what this is and Judy
made this for you
and grandma picked out the fabric for
you this is your nice little blankie
this is homemade
come here enjoy it now - here you go
look do you like it ah look how nice it
is say thank you Judy thank you grandma
not yet what are you snacking on
Starbucks yeah who is it it's me I can't
wait until tomorrow we can't say what it
is I'm not going Mia Wow 17 F Z look at
this zoom haha where's Jenna where's the
gold let's zoom out zoom out zoom out
dual the dunes Matt yeah when are the
chips gonna get delivered well you gonna
yeah we
we also have chocolate being delivered
and I'm gonna make some Lego chocolate
snacks this camera is I like this stand
what is this I hate the Jovi actually
can never get it to work you started
season 2 today was a wild day we're not
gonna get a resolute well no well
because we just started season 2 things
are getting crazy I'll see you guys
later today was a wild day I think I
might have a check Tuesday tomorrow
maybe yeah but my post is on Monday and
then nobody know what we're doing
tomorrow Matt's gonna have a very good
day tomorrow he's very excited about it
day today not tomorrow the cameras on
for me
[Music]
guys I might have made some mistakes
yeah what is this yeah I don't know I
honestly am not sure what happened to it